hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
we're gonna check out from top trending
five celebrity pranks that went wrong
I love celebrities and I love pranks put
the two together and you got videos out
celebrities show it wrong we all know
the saying it's all fun and games until
someone gets hurt well for this
installment we look at those times when
the fun just runs out trouble was close
at hand for Zach Braff JD as he's known
from the television show Scrubs chased
down and assaulted a twelve-year-old
child actor after a prank went wrong
Ashton Kutcher from MTV's Punk'd thought
it would be funny to prank Zach by
having a group of children seemingly
spray-paint his new $100,000 Porsche the
child actors were supposed to escape as
Braff remained awestruck from the prank
instead the actor would then chase after
the children and would eventually catch
up with one of them and proceeded to
beat the child mercilessly Rath would go
on record claiming I'm not a big fighter
or anything but with the adrenaline and
everything I just started pummeling him
regardless of everything MTV would go to
edit around the beating before the
episode was aired 9 another known
prankster spiked the crew of director
James Cameron's Titanic by slipping PCP
into the lobster chowder approximately
50 members were affected by the drug
instead of a drug fueled good time but
50 crew members would be checked into an
emergency room as they had all claim to
feel different and sickish the diagnosis
of the doctor the crew has been simply
stoked
needless to say not a large amount of
filming would happen that day while
filming the wolf of wallstreet co-stars
Jonah Hill and Leonardo DiCaprio were
locked in an epic struggle of pranking
one another
Leo thinking that random beatings is a
fun and exciting game friends play I'll
do just that to Jonah Hill over and over
again during the six-month stretch of
filming the movie
he'll being patient and banking on
DiCaprio's reputation as being a skilled
improviser waited for his time to exact
revenge he would find this during a
scene in which the two were eating sushi
telling DiCaprio in character that he
could have the last piece of sushi to
himself
Jonah watched as he ingested raw fish
time and time again 70 times approximate
and each take needed to be identical to
the first after eating so much raw fish
Leo would double over in vomit inducing
pain the crew would rush to his aid
making sure he was alright everyone
except Jonah Hill and director Martin
Scorsese both of whom found the
situation to be pretty damn funny ah
American rapper and actor the game
posted a tweet with a phone number
claiming callers would have a chance at
an internship working directly with him
within minutes the number was flooded
with thousands of calls effectively
jamming the phone lines for roughly two
hours a simple joke probably harmless
except the number was - the LA Sheriff's
Department Compton station infuriating
the authorities on receiving ends of the
break as they claimed any number of
callers seeking real help could have
been blocked from receiving it captain
Mike Parker would finally be able to end
the flood of calls after he tweeted to
the game - knock that [ __ ] off as it was
entirely possible the prank was
endangering people's lives when Andrew
sucks a British actor known for his role
in the show Fawlty Towers cancelled his
spot as a guest on the radio show hosted
by Russell Brand and Jonathan Ross they
would retaliate by leaving lewd and
offensive voicemails on the 79 year old
actors cell phone claiming on which
brand had an intimate relationship with
sex granddaughter Georgina Valley in the
his message brand begins talking as Ross
is heard yelling in the background hey
[ __ ] your granddaughter shortly after
that man will call back a second time to
apologize Ross would further begin to
elaborate saying she was bent over the
couch in which Brad would follow up with
an improvised song about how he
shouldn't have said that he had slept
with his granddaughter Sachs was not
amused the listeners of the radio show
were obviously not either the BBC would
go to receive 37,000 Wow can play
resulting in the two hosts paying out a
150 thousand pound fine and left poor
Bailey disowned by her grandparents no
while filming ransom Mel gets in track
down nude photos of co-star Rene Russo
who played his wife in the film after he
got hold of the photos he had portions
enlarged to poster size and laminated
them he began posting them one poster at
a time on the cruise bulletin board
allowing the cast and crew to see a
different part of a 17 year old Russo's
body Rene states he put bits and pieces
of it a breast a finger a knee and he
puts them on the bulletin board every
day now remember when he said that funny
thing about the Jews Ariana I saw him at
a bar once did he attack you
yes that's what happened the Mel Gibson
attack you cuz he picked up on your race
no race yeah isn't Jewish a race no
religion yes you know sometimes I feel
like you don't quite know my level of
knowledge some of these Frank's are
really [ __ ] up like really [ __ ] up
can't believe that broth beat up it's
well I saw that episode of punk I
definitely remember that yeah and he
totally could have totally cut off the
part repaid the kid I would have loved
to have seen that
yeah would you have done that I would
have done that from a Porsche beat up a
kid yeah they were like tagging your
pork no you would've let it go if they
were not a child I would have done
something what would you have done
first I would have called the police
how many people are there am I alone is
it nighttime there's a lot of factors
here I'm not just interested in beating
people up is the kid white or is he
Asian or is he black that's not any of
the factors that I mentioned I well
it's something you have to take into
consideration not if they're white you
can call the cops
Asian to probably negotiate with them
black just let it go right right guys
wrong all the black subs will agree with
me black out how you let it go Oh
dragging your cast yeah I heard about
that
oh my god I heard they did that because
James Cameron's a douche bag oh I didn't
know about that I heard he's like a
total dick to work with Kate Winslet
said on Titanic that she would never
work with him again because of how much
of an [ __ ] he is oh that's too bad
I know he's like I just think Slayers
that they many people got drugged yeah
and they got sent to the ER I said they
were stoned hey man I I can't tell you
know there's one time I pulled the prank
and you were around for this when I told
everyone that our friend Brandon knows
art died in an accident on Salvador and
then everyone cried what yeah I didn't
know you did that yeah I 20 insane he
was in El Salvador and I posted on
MySpace that he died in fireworks during
Christmas and his family died too I was
like 15 16 like 16 which is no valid
excuse motive no you're still bad it was
funny at the time it wasn't you know
yeah it was his idea
oh come on Brandon and then um we ruined
a few people's Christmases you're fun
dad it was funny at the time it was on
MySpace um miss those days
DiCaprio I mean really a prank though
that's a prank you're having to eat like
a bunch of raw fish is in this dialogue
it's this blocking it's not really a
praying how would he have why would
Scorsese let him eat like 70 raw fish I
know it kind of makes me hungry
and it's simply when you were turned on
by that that was weird you're like good
raw fish I mean you smelling raw fish
that's for you mrs. ba sorry just wanted
to make that joke for you
I hope you're watching I bet she's not
gonna watch that she should watch it
your mom should watch she's mad at you
she bought me drinks at the Comedy Store
she's a nice lady and you're a bad boy
that's what she wants to say to me
you're a sicko I don't even know why I'm
here
oh the police department oh yeah what
the game I mean if there's one person
that's gonna [ __ ] with the cops it's
gonna be like some type of rapper
they're the only ones who can get away
with it in the end you know black people
can't get away with it but black rappers
can get away with I can't write black
subs there's plenty of black subscribers
right guys that's the way it works don't
treat me like I'm stupid Ariana I'm not
treating you like yours I'm not ignorant
I'm not racist it's just the fact you're
a racist I'm not a racist
how is it racist by saying black rappers
have more privileged than we do when it
comes to [ __ ] with the cops
you're marginalizing a group you're
being prejudiced still just like all
Asians are good at now you're gonna say
that and all Jews run Hollywood this is
me running Holly yeah my dream that's a
guest on the real rejects
congratulations I've made it that BBC
prank the one that Russell branded
[ __ ] up that is a prank I don't agree
with you don't so they shouldn't disown
their granddaughter yeah over a nice
ridiculous that wasn't it that was like
it was just a joke and Russell Brand
like got me come on man you know call
some old guy and you're like well I
[ __ ] your granddaughter that's [ __ ]
up man kind of funny but [ __ ] up I
would have liked to have been there I'm
sure I could find the audio online I
find weird stuff funny you know they
brought up Mel Gibson you know what I
thought was really funny and this is
true I genuinely thought was funny when
he had those like phone calls to his
ex-girlfriend and he was like losing his
cool yeah it wasn't funny though and it
was kind of scary but like some of the
[ __ ] he said was pretty funny you're
supposed to blow me come on fun I had to
sell my Laker tickets cuz of you people
are crazy yeah yeah especially the
Gibson but I like no gifts and I think
he's one of the most talented people in
Hollywood I know your mom hates them
that's something about Jewish people
whatever people can't take a joke
apparently I'm taking them I don't feel
like you like being here I like being
here do you I'm just thinking of like a
defense mechanism was yours like you
look big dick and I'm like what what do
I say that I haven't said you like big
dick once in this video well maybe in
the other you're just talking about
yourself liking big dick big dick freak
me I don't even watch it in form it just
intimidates me you know you understand
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to the real Rejects feel like
we're on a talk show with technically
this is a talk show and you could check
out ariana ba story on her youtube
channel
ariana ba sory ten you could follow her
Facebook Instagram Twitter me on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope and let's catch up on some
shoutouts here
Allen Bryant I love your vids dude keep
up the good work
hashtag Ryan's boss let's I thought he
was saying he is Ryan's boss let's see
what you look like kiddo he's a kid he's
a young lad yeah don't laugh at him I'm
not laughing at her laughing at him I'm
not laughing when I pull at the picture
you try not well that he's a young lad
and oh yeah okay come on that wasn't
funny what I said you that cuz you saw
his photo this is a funny picture he's
just done an arcade bicycle that's
hilarious
it's kind of a funny looking it's a
funny picture funny looking kid
especially this photo where he looks
like he's taking his [ __ ] outside
getting a hot song my handsome grandsons
buy back sorry dude